[Music]
please welcome the very funny baron
vaughn
[Music]
[Applause]
me me me thank you thank you very much
hello audience if that's your real name
um i am an adult which means i am just
now starting to accept the fact that
i'll never have superpowers and that
ruins all of my plans it was get
superpowers then fix my credit
and um i don't know how i'm going to do
the second without the first i clearly
don't understand that industry
but i have tried to move things with my
brain at home you know i will i'll be at
home watching tv or having a meal and
the remote of the fork is just out of
reach and i don't want to quote unquote
get up
so instead i just concentrate i'm just
like perhaps now and my brain's like go
go gadget i'm like yes brain very funny
but take this seriously
and nothing happens but if one day that
fork flew into my hand i wouldn't be
surprised
that's how much i've thought about that
if it was just like shloop
as i suspected
i happen to have an outfit picked up for
this mask cape time to stop dubstep
my greatest weakness is uh it's really
old black southern women that go to
church three or more times a week
because i will do literally anything
they ask me to do
especially if they call me sugar like
if an old black woman's like excuse me
she'll i'm like well i am sweet
how can i be of assistance what that
lifting things to the bake sale
all black women have a trump card that i
can't deny it doesn't matter what i'm in
the middle of the old black woman comes
up to me is like excuse me baby can you
help me with these groceries my
elevator's broke you see and i can't go
up all themselves with all these
groceries sugar
because my bones
my bones are just so brittle
you know from marching for your rights
just remember the seventh floor ain't as
far as selma to montgomery baby
i tried to quit sugar i failed i'll try
again and i'll fail because sugar's in
everything
and it is hard to quit it's the greatest
drug of all time because it hurts us and
it's legal i think that heroin and
cocaine uh wish they were sugar i think
they had posters of sugar in their walls
when they were in high school
and they used to go to sleep going one
day i'll be in breakfast which
is my biggest weakness breakfast cereals
oh man you ever notice that sugary
cherries are on like the bottom shelf of
the cereal aisle and healthy stuff's at
the top so when i at 2 a.m finally find
a 24-hour grocery store to indulge in my
shame i'm told a story as my gaze drops
of who i should be as opposed to who i
actually am
because it's kind of like hey right
there for you eye level because you're
an adult kashi
eat that you're not sure what's in it
you're not even sure if you said it
correctly
but it's got to be great there's
pictures of wheat on the box look at the
one next to them they're hugging and
smiling know why because they're going
to live past 40.
kashi eat that then look down one more
hey corn chex is totally fine man corn
chex is good look 12 essential vitamins
and nutrients very important i've been
told corn chex still doing great one
more shelf
i'm losing you a little bit honey nut
cheerios okay um
it's cheerios so that's good but i'll
tell you my biggest concern
there's a cartoon
on the box
but
it is a cartoon bee and at least bees
exist
as long as you stay with illustrations
of things that are things you're doing
okay honey nut cheerios i'll accept it
last shelf elves aren't real why is that
tiger wearing a scarf he shouldn't be
cold he's covered in fur that captain
does not look licensed to operate a
vessel on the milk seas
and you're going after a cereal that
features the modern stone age family
that's not a thing you can't have a
small brontosaurus as a dog they never
existed
keep it up you're gonna end up just like
this diabetic vampire
thank you very much
[Applause]